اذا بالمسيرات والهجمات الصاروخيه ضربت
القوات الاوكرانيه بوتين في عقر داره
سوافي بالقرود او العاصمه مؤخرا غير
نابوتين صمت بشكل غير معتاد لا بل ان عدم
احتراثه ظهر وكان شيئا لم يحدث هذا السلوك
اي التظاهر بعدم الانزعاج فسرته صحيفه
واشنطن بوست على انه محاوله لاظهار
الاحساس بالهدوء والسيطره فيما وصفه
محللون بمحاوله لمنع تململ الذعر بين شعبه
وصرف الانتباه نقاط الضعف في دفاعات روسيا
فرئيس روسي اكتفى بالاشاره الى عمل نظام
الدفاع الجوي بشكل جيد متهما كيف بترهيب
والاستفزاز سياسيون وصقور مؤيدون للحرب
انتقدوا فشل موسكو في منع طائرات بدون
طيار من دخول المجال الجوي للعاصمه
مطالبين اياها برد اشد قسوه كما تقول
الصحيفه الامريكيه اما يفج ين برغوجين
فرئيس مجموعه فاغنر هو الاخر استغرب ما
يحصل متسائلا عن سبب السماح لهذه المسيرات
بالتحليق الى موسكو فيما دعى بيترتل سوي
نائب رئيس مجلس الدوما البرلمان الروسي له
احتلال وذهبت بعض التوقعات الى وجود خطط
لتطبيق الاحكام العرفيه لكن المتحدث باسم
كوف نفى اي مناقشات بهذا الخصوص شاكيا عدم
انتقاد الغرب للهجوم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات